[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from 14 nations converge in st.
Louis as US chess champs calm presents
the third annual spring chess classic
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for another installment of the
seasonal classic tournament my name is
Ben Simon and I'm joined today by
Grandmaster Oman Hamilton the best
partner ever for the first time ever
Amon welcome to the show
thank you it's a pleasure having you
next to me the world-famous Amon
Hamilton how psyched are you to be here
Wow wait an introduction there I've had
a little caffeine today well thank you
very much I'm happy to be here it's my
first time I guess commentating
tournament like this and I am a little
excited to be Co casting with you been
first time for that as well well the
cookie crumbled in the right places
because this is the strongest classic
yet this is the third annual spring
chess classic 14 nations represented and
not only is it potentially the most
diverse field ever but we have some top
100 players and I want to take a look at
the field for our masters division group
a this is the big dogs this is where
they play this is their yard leanly
grandmaster lee lee you know his name
all across the world he is our top seed
from Vietnam
the legendary Vasilyev on top he is
world number 44 he showed up a little
bit late for the round today missed his
head shot we don't have a photo of him
but I'm sure that all the chess fans out
there who know who's who no even shook
yeah
we have Ray Robson and Jeffrey's young
the US Championship competitors that's
the next big tournament we're presenting
here in st. Louis Bruce Timm Kasim Shan
off the 2004 feed a world champion and
then we also have a lot of awesome
players here in the bottom half the
tournament the Netherlands benjamin bak
alien is nick the winner of the most
recent world open varoujan Akopian
actually Akopian won the world open
several years ago as well and is
returning group a champion in this field
and then will be seen re ant re and then
your buddy
erik hansen in the field as well just
rounding off the bottom of the table
there Ben you know I can't forget about
the Canadians we like to sneak in on the
caboose well it's all about whether or
not he can bring high energy to this
event you know what Low Energy and
something like this no no absolutely not
he's got his work cut out for him there
at the bottom of the table all
grandmasters in this field but over in
Group B there is maybe some norm pass
abilities because we have eight
grandmasters and then an international
master and even a fee that master at the
bottom by ginchy at the very top from
China one of the few we've had Chinese
players play in the classic series
before actually Joo Won Jun played here
before she was the women's world
champion Alexander Misa from Poland
number two Audrey baarish pullets a
former groupie champion in his own right
and that is his preferred spelling of
his first name for those of you out
there correcting us already
Sergei Arenberg former US Championship
competitor a few times over Christian
korilla what a personality he is on the
YouTube channel yeah and also a fierce
competitor representing Romania and a
Stein Grimson from Iceland
Nicholas Theodore oh we've seen him
before from Greece Denis coverage from
Bosnia we're seeing him for the first
time
Gregory Kadena and then Alexey Sorokin
Sorokin actually has two Grand Master
norms he has like a million
international master norms but he's
never petitioned to be and I am and he
could earn that GM title in this
tournament which is the one which is the
final one so he could become a Grand
Master in this tournament and you know
sitting there the lowest seed he's got
probably the best the best chance he's
got a bunch of high rated players to
play yeah and his unique situation in
this part of the world least are in this
city we'll talk about a little bit later
on let's take a look at our tournament
format it's easy to understand we've got
210 player round robins the time control
is 90 minutes for the first 40 moves and
then once they make time control they
get 30 minutes added onto each clock
there's a 30 second increment from move
number one so players do have to take
notation the entire game there's a 30
move draw rule in place to encourage
fighting chess in this event I think
that's good
I'm a fan of that rule it well it works
against me usually because I like to
make a draw and just just leave really
maybe yeah Ben Feingold and I actually
quite a few those would never know you
would never know
okay and as far as our schedule we don't
have a rest day guys we are going at
this nine days straight that's right
this is round number one now the rounds
begin each day at 1:00 p.m. Central Time
the final day will begin two hours early
it's also daylight saving time so it's
gonna feel like three hours early and
that's all because we will have a
playoff if necessary later on that same
day we will be on the air with you each
day two and a half hours after the start
of the round and we will be on the air
until the likely conclusion or getting
close to the conclusion of each round at
5 p.m. central we invite you to join us
on YouTube and Facebook and Twitter
hashtag spring at chess classic we will
have the YouTube chat open so be nice
gonna be perusing the comments yes keep
them honest banhammer will be in effect
don't mess up but we will if you have
any thoughtful questions let us know
okay so the game started a couple hours
ago yeah here's what's going on in Group
A this is our masters division let's
take a look at the pairings Rhea Robson
vs. roost M cows and Jonna Hylian is
Nick vs. Jeffrey Jean Vasilyev on
summers version of Cobian re an Atari
vs. Eric Hanson and our key matchup
today is Benjamin Bach versus liam lee
two grandmasters two very strong players
Benjamin Bach of course could knock off
one of the best players in the world
this is his opportunity this is gonna be
a good game and actually I want to take
a look at where we are in the game thus
far yeah absolutely well Benjamin Bach
first of all he's he's studying at the
st. Louis University if I'm not mistaken
so he's he's studying pretty much every
day and look long lamb is very similar
he's that he's at Webster so both of
these guys are are very up to date on on
some of their their theory so why don't
we maybe just take a quick peek at at
how we got here from the start here so
d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 and g3 bye bye
Benjamin here
so already he's he's sort of committing
to well a lot of players after g3 what
they decide to play sometimes is c5 and
try to get a Benoni
Frank at Ovid benoni which is which is
often that considered to be pretty good
for for black or at least if you're
gonna play a Benoni you you want to play
this one so a lot of players actually
decide to to play c5 against that g3
move I know myself I've played it before
so he decides instead to go for just
Bishop before and transform the lines
back into more of a Catalan type of type
of structure but 92 by by Benjamin is a
little bit different you would often
maybe more more associate Bishop d2 move
and that's that's I think pretty pretty
standard par for the course Bishop d2
and you can take that or black sometimes
goes push it back to e7 and just follows
with d5 so 92 I would say it's just a
little bit different bye bye Benjamin
and inviting a different type of middle
game than most of the regular Catalans
alright Bishop g2 right so Castle b6 and
castles by white Bishop e7 now these
positions are like I was saying they're
a little bit different so because of the
move Knight d2
we don't really see I mean it's not in
blacks interest all the time to play
Bishop takes d2 you know so something
like a 3 B 4 quick expansion by white on
the on the Queen side is a lot more a
lot more possible in this situation
because you've got that bishop that has
black you you kind of want to preserve
so black is going to be playing like
Bishop d6 or Bishop e7 maybe going for
the move c5 himself and the other way to
play it is is to sort of quickly get
that 94 and and f5 and get that grip on
the on the center of the board so we'll
see if look long and goes for for
something like that but that's the main
difference I think with not having that
big
chip on d2 is basically you don't get to
trade that that dark square bishop off
so you can sort of get pushed around a
3p for getting a bit of space there in
the queenside b3 Bishop b2 and okay we
we I guess we see this plan from from
laQuan which is 94 and yet actually he
just goes for f5 kind of like I was
saying but White's Knights are set up a
bit a bit nicely for this because
sometimes you have the idea of 95 this
and I can go to f3 this Knight can even
drop back to d3 and then you maintain a
really nice grip on the e5 square you
got this Bishop on b2 knight on f3
Knight on d3 all working towards the e5
square and by playing 95 you also
unleash this this Bishop on the bishop
on b7 so you've got that very
uncomfortable diagonal where where the
d5 pawn sort of feels the pressure from
from the pin and and maybe even consider
it move like f3 try to kick this night
out on a 4 so as far as what bak can do
basically get an octopus Knight right
there on e5 is that right because the
pawns on D and F are too far advanced to
stop it
right yeah you can't really kick the
knight on on e5 out with a pawn so in
order to to get rid of the night you're
gonna have to take and I think it's in
blacks interest to take a knight on e5
before white gets a chance to play let's
say Knight d2 f3 because then when you
take it it can be replaced by another
night so if I was black at on the move
and 85 I'd be looking to take it
straight away essentially but White has
a you know white White has to work
before you can play 95 right so we're
probably gonna see a 3 to make sure that
night on d2 is not hanging and yeah a
395 Knight f3 seems like a reasonable
plan I think another way you could do
things is kick the bishop first and then
even consider Nighy 1 Knight f3 and 93
so similar rerouting but you don't give
black a chance to
to trade off because really bet if I had
it my way I would like to occupy e5 with
a piece not a pawn so if I play 95 and
you take and I have to play D takes I'm
not thrilled about it it's not bad but
if I could have it my way I'd love to
just put a knight on e5 you take me I
put another Knight there that would be
ideal
yeah so he sort of goes for this get
that quick before and I mean Benjamin's
got a very comfortable position here as
we just sort of go forward and 95 was
played I think he could have easily
decided to go for something like this
but sometimes it's a little slow and
what happens is you know blacks going
for some sort of kingside initiative
here right the queen is coming out this
night could slide into g4 with pressure
on f2 and nh-2 here and you know it's
it's a little scary well I'm still at
the the childish age in chess where I
move like g5 just scares me it's just a
scary move like it's a lot of sometimes
it's a lot of ponies it's not a puns
yeah
you know I don't have all the answers it
was like why is g5 a bad move I don't
have the answers looks like a great move
scaring me I think it's a great move so
you know it moves like this are gonna
happen and it's especially scary when a
player like 2700 player like laQuan
plays g5 because then he's got the
intimidation and you know that he's
probably backed it up with actual
calculation and I don't think there's
anything scarier than a pawn storm
that's initiated by 2700 yeah there
comes that big haymaker here comes
what's he gonna do so he decides to go
right in with 95 and we basically get
this this position here which clarifies
I think this is kind of an important
moment where each takes d5 is played if
the other move C takes d5 would be
played I'll just show a little bit
because I think it's a bad move but you
know the C file gets open rook c7 is a
big threat and this knight can slide
into the d4 square where it's gonna hit
the pawn on e6 threatening o knight c6 I
mean I think white just has a tremendous
position here so laQuan liam smartly
does not not venture into any of those
complications because white i think is
just simply better after after C takes
d5 so he wants to go he takes d5 he
gives white a protected pass pawn you
know potentially why - ever wants to
that's that's for the endgame but he
plays c5 seeing wants to control d4 he's
not letting that night John
then and he wants to open up this bishop
on on b7 which is has been asleep for
the Wow it's been it's been sitting
there waiting to to come into the action
but after c5 b takes e5 he throws in the
move Bishop c6 that's what we call 2700
move just you know he could take back to
pawn but no of course he's planning
Bishop c6 because that Bishop was
hanging on b7 he wants to take with the
pond and maintain control that square he
couldn't do that so he throws in this
move he's intending Bishop a4 winning
material and so Benjamin goes Queen a2
now he takes back B takes e5 and I think
this is our current position after the
f3 here and it looks like you can see on
the camera there
Benjamin's doing one of those confident
get up from the tables you know f3 mic
drop you think he has the edge right
here
well problem is when you drop the mic
and the guy makes you sit back down at
the table then I don't think there's
anything more embarrassing and I think
getting up from the board and as you're
in like mid stride I moves him like okay
I'm just getting up for a nice stroll
around the room I'm just gonna sit right
back down yeah I'm just gonna sit right
back down
so yeah f3 was played and Benjamin's
basically dealing with this with this
knight on e4 and in response to that
very quickly
laQuan plate 95 and you know he's not
being cryptic here he wants to bring
that night to e6 Knights are the best
block aiders of pass pawns
so he's gonna stick that night right in
front of it and it's gonna support the
c5 pawn it's gonna block the e pawn it's
gonna support them with d5 later on in
the future and you know even if we think
of a position let's say white goes H 496
f4 and just sort of plugs everything
black has slow ways to break through
with with age 6 and g5 and you have to
kind of look at White's pieces and say
you know what where is this night going
in the future
b3 I don't see any major squares a5 is
pretty offside f3
really go anywhere past that so I'm I'm
liking a look Long's position for
example if you can serve reroute his
night to the e6 square
I don't think Benjamin is gonna go for
the news I was just suggesting but that
was just to illustrate exactly what
black wants to he can put his knight on
e6 and say that he still got g5 to
expand with he's got a passed pawn on
the C file black so it is pretty
balanced like that and for the most part
if you have those hanging pawns in the
center d5 and c5 if you can protect them
and it looks like look long has done
just that then and then usually black is
doing quite well or anyone who has the
hanging pawns so so you can defend them
and keep them then they advance control
a lot of central squares and if you look
at the time advantage it's another
indicator that look Wong is is probably
slightly more comfortable than than
Benjamin here as they remove what 2821
so still still a few moves to catch up
on 25 minutes to nine minutes here as
the top seed takes on Benjamin block
Benjamin balk Benjamin Bloch I like Ben
Ben I have to adjust that I'm saying
Benjamin Benjamin Benjamin a lot of
international players here okay well
let's take a look at our first time well
first of all a YouTube chat is very
active I want to thank everybody for
watching this Logan Baker says he's
rooting for Vaughn Chuck and a Cobian I
think a lot of people are two of the
real favorites in Group A but let's jump
over to Group B for the first time and
introduce you to these players in our
challengers division by ginchy versus
Adrian Stein Grimson of iceland Andre
Irish poets the former B champion
against Christian korilla Gregory
Caetano US Championship veteran versus
Dennis Catterick Nicholas theodoro
versus Alexey Sorokin and our key
matchup and this is just by combined
highest reddick rating because no one
has knee points yet Grandmaster Sergei
Arenberg vs. Grandmaster Alexander Mista
of Poland let's take a look at this game
sure bring that up and I think that I
think that this game is definitely one
to keep an eye on kind of to two players
that you might expect to be
to be frontrunners for for this group
overall and actually totally different
from the game we just looked at right in
terms of liquidation almost everything
is off the board here which should make
it a little more a little more obvious
who who's doing well or whether we're
just headed to a draw well and I'm
curious what move they're on because
I'll also look at the time deficit these
four white or move 31 there okay so we
have nine more moves to go until time
control and then I'll both get thirty
minutes added on to their clock but
thirty eight minutes for Vista and the
American is down to five what's going on
in this game Amman right so just you
know I'm not not like a superhuman I
just count the pawns first there been
one two we have the wrong guy I'm very
sorry everyone
one two three four five one two three
four it's the first thing you do just
count them up but okay this pawn at age
six no surprises is a goner black is
gonna take this pretty soon in terms of
past pawns
white can make one over here and it's
gonna be an outside pass pawn but black
is coming with with one on g4 as well I
have to say offhand this looks extremely
dry because it looks like the the H bond
is going to fall it looks like the
bishops have a very good chance of being
traded if anyone is is playing for a win
I don't know maybe I mean I just think
it's probably drawn I think it's maybe
dead wrong
but maybe White's playing for a win I'm
not sure I don't think any either player
here could really fool themselves too
much into thinking that they're gonna
win this game because essentially blacks
gonna get a passed pawn White's gonna
get a passed pawn I suppose if I had to
say maybe black's pawn is a little bit
faster you know it's already on g5
you're one step from g4 you can support
it with your king and white on the other
hand yes to do some work to to play a 3
B 4 let's not forget if you play a 3 and
a lot of these lines you know you might
actually run into for example if I take
let's say what just wants to make it
past poem sometimes you run into a four
and I make it a little bit hard for you
to just go ahead and make that pass pawn
so sometimes that can happen but yeah
again I don't think I don't think either
players gonna win 36 minutes to 5
minutes I think that's relevant with
when you're on move 32 even if you get
that extra time I think Arenberg has to
be quite conscious of that you know you
let that time slip down then you can
easily blunder draw into a loss but I
have to say offhand this looks this
looks quite equal but you know Mesa has
got to be sitting comfortably right with
that much time and easy calculations
ahead well before we get to of the rest
of our games which we might see some
decisions I'm certain let's take a look
at our prize funds first of all for our
group a the grand prize the champ walks
away with $6,000 and really no one's
going home empty-handed 4,000 3,000
2,000 by the way for all the details of
this tournament join us at us chest
champs calm you can see the entire
breakdown of every detail in this event
let's take a look at group B's prize
fund still not too shabby $4,000 for the
B champion going down to at least $500
total grand prize combined $36,000 fund
it's gonna be there's a lot to fight for
this event and this event is really
unique because from May until December
we see the grand chest or and then we
see the feed a world championship cycle
we see all of these really big elite
players and this is really the next step
down we're introducing to the players
that you might be seen in the elite
events in the years to come
maybe not but their faces their names
with interesting stories and we're gonna
learn about them in this campaign for
the next nine days okay it's time to dig
in Aman oh it's time to dig it's time to
dig in let's take a look at our other
games besides our key matchups right has
anything caught your eye well it seems
to me like the the game between Ray
Robson and roost M Kasim Janov seems to
be
what's already imbalanced that it seems
like roost m-maybe maybe got something
early on in this game in terms of
potential advantage because you know you
joined the position here and already
with the black pieces where stem chasm
channel is you should be playing for for
something here you obviously the the
position is not clear but he's not
material here and Ray Robson it seemed
like they were both engaging in a very
theoretical battle early on I think this
came from a Sicilian and what I see here
is the potential for for Bruce them
definitely playing for the win but I I
don't think this is easy at all White's
got great control of the d5 square
bishop can come to g2 for example he's
got pressure on h7 and f5 but material
speaks for itself
banned in positions like this so as long
as black is not you know let's say
losing a pawn on d6 or f5 they're weak
but he's not losing material there it is
technically a just a basically a pawn
and a knight for a rook so so definite
advantage for Kasim Janov here as as
both of these player move 25 both these
players relatively low on the clock but
but nothing too scary just yet and Kasim
Janov is he must be the oldest player in
the field by far I think no no I don't
think so I'm fixing the few wait oh well
yeah so okay Dino is also he's not in
this field I know I need some a let's
say yeah group a yeah Yvan truck is 49
you got Chucky in the field yeah no
that's true that's true but Kasim Jenna
I mean he's the gears are still turning
there he's he's a favorite here for sure
yeah and absolutely if I'm white here
I'm feeling a little bit suppressed I'm
feeling a little bit suffocated in this
position both of these players are just
integral to us chess right now we know
that wisdom does not play under the
US flag but he is the second to Fabiano
Carolina of course I just played in the
World Championship and both Bobby and
Ray Robson are on the Olympiad team
right consistently and they were on the
gold medal winning Olympian team in 2016
so this is this is in a way an
all-american matchup and not on paper
that's right no that's a good point it I
think a lot of people are familiar you
know people's seconds and chest don't
always go very notice a lot of that goes
sort of behind the scenes under the
table you could name a top player and
probably he has a you know five to ten
seconds who nobody knows about you don't
always make those connections publicly
but Kasim jennife has been a very public
second and coach and trainer for four
fabbi for a long time so I think a lot
of people are actually familiar with in
for that reason and and you know he
probably has a few extra extra fans
absolutely yeah after after f5 which has
just been been playing on the board it
looks like you can see there Ray is
having to think in his in his bright
little blazer there that is the actually
the US chess blazer that the Olympiad
team members got right yeah yeah I
recognized it from the from the Olympiad
and what was he just played I think he
just came out with the move B 4v4 on the
board he's trying to wrangle some
control of the center here it's it feels
like the move f4 is something to watch
out for in general but the nice thing
about before is as you can see is you
know we got a queen here which is
watching the d6 pawn and the f5 pawn so
he's trying to say b4 and whether or not
he's committing to to a certain move
he's just saying what are you doing next
which pawn do you care more about
because I don't see a way to necessarily
watch over both of them and you know for
example Queen c7 watch over d6 you've
made your choice
I can probably go grab this pawn now I
takes f5
you know you've made the c3 pawn weaker
by by playing before but you know no the
d6 pawn is hanging bishop's well not
hanging but I could I could remove all
the cover from from the black King in
the next move so is there any way to get
the white bishop active ever I think I
think he's probably well the one thing
is you know the slow way is just if you
can get that Bishop on d5 then I'm very
happy that the pawn on g3 also stops at
four which is quite nice so I'm really
watching out for for blacks main threat
while activating my bishop and giving my
King an escape square so I think I think
g3 is an easy way to do that but
otherwise the bishops actually doing a
tremendous job here which is maybe going
unnoticed but it's it's preventing back
rank checkmate you know almost every
line so when I get when I get happy that
I'm winning upon here in f5 maybe it's
only possible because of that Bishop on
f1 so in some ways I don't really need
to activate that Bishop it's doing quite
a good job on f1 it's facilitating
everything else to happen and then when
it comes to an end game you know it's
going to be ready to to jump out and and
pressure some of these Queen side pawns
so ray Robson's position looks very very
solid right now he's got a an easy
position visually bishop on f1 is nice
for example fine Kasim Shanno right now
I'm looking at this position and I'm
saying Queen c7 which was just a move
that I put out there I don't like it at
all
I mean losing the f5 pawn is it's just a
no-go for me in this position then so
I'm playing with Queen c8 which I think
is almost forced I have to guard this
pawn and you know if you go take this
pawn all of a sudden Queen takes c3
might get a little messy so I'm playing
Queen c8 and threatening maybe to play
the move f4 look for a Queen trade with
Queen takes h3 and and try to simplify
but I see he's actually played Queen F
Queen c8 excuse me on the board and
responded to quickly with f4 so the last
two moves by ray Robson are compromising
to the king to the pawn structure right
this diagonal is a little bit weaker
it's pawn is a little bit weaker but
it's all for one
one goal he wants to win that pond and
he's saying that he's going to by force
at four where's this rook going f5 is
he's gonna be hanging you can't move the
rook anywhere here so let's say move
like you know rook rook e7 doesn't look
too good you just walk into Knight takes
at five and other than that you've got
rookie six and Mike takes F five still
bishop on f1 is still still doing work
this this is Ray actually saying that
you know I can compromise my my position
like this because it's concrete he's
saying that I can win a pawn and pawn on
f5 is very valuable in this position d6
pawn is hanging after that
it's actually kind of nice that you see
the Queen and rook working so nicely
together last move the knight couldn't
be taken on what the knight can be taken
and might actually be but because the
the move f4 looks a little loose B got
that clean they're watching the knight
the rooks watching the pawn one thing to
consider if your York as much on/off
here is that you sort of pull the plug
option whether or not this is is
something he wants to do today it takes
takes takes and Queen takes on c3 and
try to say that this this maybe is equal
opposite bishops sort of liquidating
down it felt the last couple moves that
Rey was sort of generating mini
initiative right he's kicking the ropes
back kickin queens back are we going for
this as chasm Janov or are we dealing
with a position where white plays Knight
takes f5 I think that's what he's
thinking about right now
I think he's concerned as the time ticks
down as he evaluates his opponents
compensation here that it might be too
much so you look at this position and
you feel like maybe you have good chance
at equality or you look at this position
and you know do you really want to put
up with this that this is what I'm
wondering so offhand I think there's
actually a very decent chance
you may actually consider brooked ac3
sort of bailing out and and going for
that position well we'll see if that
happens indeed let's move on to another
game here one that caught my eye in
Group A was your boy Eric Hanson oh yeah
Chesbrough absolutely gladion sorry an
Atari of Norway let's check it out so we
got ya Ari and Terry from from Norway
who's was quite a young competitor
himself playing Hansen in oh that's
right I didn't even have to look at
which side Hansen was playing I just had
to look at the time just have to look at
the time it's just a little alarming you
know three minutes now it's basically a
blitz game so you know we play a lot of
that this is comfort zone territory for
for Hansen so far a very relatable
position for myself as well so yeah I I
knew he'd be he'd be playing black here
but what I see off hand is a pardon me
just for one moment we do have a result
our first of the day a group bit on in
Group B Andre bearish bullets and
Kristine korilla have drawn they're gone
okay so the first first points on the
board are half points so they're leading
the tournament you're saying bit they
are in the lead Wow off to a quick what
I thought gorilla and bargepole it's
really securing the bishops of opposite
color early sprints not much out ahead
okay yeah let's get back to this game
here
yeah know that this one I mean they're
right in the heart of time pressure as a
result of Hansen's clock and the Atari
is quite comfortable there with 20 over
20 minutes as they're on the move 26 but
it seems like I mean I can look at this
position and already say that white is
definitely going to be a bit better
black has got the two bishops but it's
that Bishop on b7 that needs you need to
play some sort of f5 move to break up
the team in the centre the pawn on e4
the pawn on d5 you need to force White's
apply e5 so that the D pawn will be
hanging but I mean
I mean Tori's sorry he's not a pushover
he's not just gonna Bend like oh you
want to do that let me help you out if
that five happens these bishops are
gonna get traded the Knights gonna jump
to e5 we've got a pawn hanging here on
on b6 as well so no this is a this has
got to be a better position for for Tory
here for white because I see that the
Grunfeld bishop this looks like it came
from Grunfeld I see that grünfeld bishop
on g7 has been blunted you've been
forced to play the move f6 here as as
black that's never a good feeling for
fruitful player it's that's kind of like
you're a SERP right of butter right
there you don't want to lock that in but
obviously he's had to do so as a result
of some middlegame complications and
this bishop here is also just never
gonna get open without the move f5 and
as I was explaining that's also in
whites favors so Hansen has actually
played the move
h4 in this position which makes a lot of
sense he's trying to chip away at the
pawn structure in front of Tory's King
here and basically we got this and this
is the two weak points in the position
maybe Hansen's going to continue with
some of these type of moves but I feel
like White's position is as far superior
and tactically especially as maybe time
ticks down and Hansen doesn't have time
to calculate everything usually start to
rely on your instincts a bit more I feel
like the tactics are going to be in
audience favor here so it's that Bishop
on b7 it's a little worrying for me well
I must be really worrying because it
strikes me as odd you did identified the
two weak points of the position the
whites weak point is over by the white
king whereas blacks is not yet you
prefer white yeah well it's not always
about not always about attacking not
always about attacking remember always I
really like to attack okay
the nice thing though is that my weak
point front of my king let's say I play
King g2 I've got my queen on b3 I can
defend that twice you can't actually add
any firepower to that G pawn
whereas your pawn on d6 is already
attacked twice and it's not defended at
all and you
can't be defended at all on the next
move so that's why I sort of look at
this in and feel like white has that
that natural initiative here because you
see we see a pond that just can't be
defended and Eric it means that Eric is
gonna have to deal with the threats
tactically and when you have just a
limited amount of time that becomes
harder and harder to do so essentially
he's gonna have to rationalize himself
for two minutes on the clock
I'm losing this pawn he's gonna have to
go for complications and with 20 minutes
on the clock you'd expect Atari to be
able to sort of deal with those with
wrong calculation but we are gonna see
probably something quite drastic from
from Hanson the next couple moves
whether it's a pawn sacrifice what b6 is
going no matter what but whether it's
like I was saying these F v g5 type of
moves maybe taking here trying to get a
rook to H a something crazy let's not
forget the queen is also lined up at the
king so you know if you take here and
some sort of d6 move comes in this is
looking worse and worse for for Eric
right off right off the bat here is a
first impression looks like Eric just
played Bishop a6 right so the pawn was
captured okay that makes sense
takes takes and you just took it because
he's saying he's saying the Queen is
covering g3 and Eric played Bishop a6
right so this makes sense the bishop on
b7 just didn't have any scope there was
nothing to do so he may as well put the
bishop here maybe you have ideas like
bringing the bishop here bring it to f3
blocking that Queen from defending the
pawn some ideas there also hitting the
e4 pawn so I think that's reasonable as
well but fishpond a6 looks looks correct
that's where I want to put that Bishop
you've still got pressure on g3 and we
also have this idea of an overworked
piece so maybe try to say that hey this
queen is actually guarding this pawn and
this Knight so maybe I have to move like
rook b8 you have ideas like sacrificing
and really playing H takes g3 so our en
is gonna have to be very very weary of
his jeep on as well as a move like
Bishop e2 as I was mentioning which
threatens rook takes e4 it threatens the
rope and
maybe threatens Bishop f3 disconnecting
the queena for the pawn so this is sort
of us it what I was saying is that I
think Hanson's gonna take a very
tactical approach right now he's lost
that pawn he knows he's not gonna get it
back he probably knows his position is
worse but he's gonna try to create a
very messy position which which he's
gonna he's gonna need tactics to to
survive this well it's coming down to
crunch time so I think in the interest
of looking as much as possible we should
take a look at another game now
Tariana tari is the 2017 world junior
champion he's 19 years old we have
another world junior champion play in
the field the 2016 world junior champion
Geoffrey Zhang in his game I cannot tell
in his game with iliyan is Nick if the
Queens are just both deadly or they're
just completely out of play right let's
take a look here so we've got Ilya
initiative Geoffrey Jon he's playing
black here and as you were pointing out
it's it's hard to tell whether this
Queen on a 2 is actually planning to you
know catapult itself into the position
or if Geoffrey has you know some sort of
magical hold as we can see here which is
kind of funny every single square on
that diagonal he's he's managed to cover
but that also means that he's stuck with
those pieces on those exact squares if
he wants to keep the Queen out so this
queen is waiting to to enter the
position somehow he's got controlled the
C file and for now he's controlling as I
was mentioning all these key squares
that being said it looks like Ilias
position is is fairly compact here he's
got Bishop d6 which is gonna disrupt the
placement of this Knight as an idea so
he's probably gonna have to facilitate
that with like King F 1 if he wants to
do that alternatively Bishop a5 does the
same thing
Bishop f3 looks like a move that I would
be very interested in playing with the
idea of following up what say here is
it's actually Ilyas move so let's say
something like this takes
so what does that do it helps my queen
get in the position now I've got rid of
your bishop and what I want to do next
display King to g2 and suddenly I'm out
of the pin maybe I'll play f4 next
Knight f3 and my pieces seem to be
developing getting active and I am a
little bit concerned for Geoffrey's
position here if if white can achieve
something like that so I think Bishop f3
Bishop a5 these are all reasonable moves
here but I'm concerned for for
Geoffrey's position because these pawns
here on the Queen side are not mobile
they can't move at all and this Bishop
f3 move honestly looks looks quite
strong here this Bishop f3 move maybe is
unless unless there's some tactics to to
worry about but what I'm doing then I'm
building a fortress right once I trade
the bishops let's say I play pawn takes
King on g2 is so safe I mean there's no
checks my king is completely safe and
all I can do then is just bring the
Queen in and suddenly is blacks King
blacks pieces which which are a little
bit dis coordinated and I might play f4
like I said get that Knight into the
action and I think once White's pieces
all leap off the back rank you you start
to realize this black that what you have
right now is more of a temporary
solution you've got the Queen locked out
you've kind of got White's pieces locked
on the back row but you've got to
continue keeping that up and I'm not
sure that he that he can't you know it
feels like it's got an expiry date
almost two results here you don't think
that Nick has a chance of losing this
one well he's he's got a healthy time
advantage right now which is another
thing although I should also point out
that these guys are very close to time
control so I don't think that's gonna be
an issue for Geoffrey who's also you
know got a lot of experience playing
playing these these type of games well
he's going to get too nervous here but I
think you can always you can always
let's say say that this position has
three results but to me
Ilia losing is quite unlikely quite
unlikely here he's played through Bishop
a5 and I think this makes a lot of sense
he this was one of the moves I wanted to
get in he's still guarding his knight
only one he's pressuring this Knight and
he
saying you know next move I just want to
get the Queen into one of these squares
it's gonna happen so Bishop f3 Queen
into the position I think Illya is doing
very well here been well we'll have to
keep an eye on this game let's move on
to another group be spectacular by
ginchy verses he hadn't Stein the
Grissom Grimson rather right now China
versus Iceland not uh not two countries
expect be facing off in st. Louis no
that's variable very international what
do we have here
bhaijan she's also the we should say the
top top seed right yes yeah in the B
group and what do we have here both
players actually quite low on time so
really then I move 23 this is shaping up
to be potentially just a just a time
scramble at this point and looking at
the position everything is is fairly
even we've got you know just two ropes
the Queen at Bishop the piece and both
players actually have a loose pawn you
know that what the rook is hitting the C
pawn works hitting the EEP on both the
Queen on c6 and the bishop on you two
are gonna have to move so the only
reason that I would say maybe I think
it's just dead even but if if I had to
sort of give a preference maybe black
has some depending on where white puts
the Queen maybe black has some ideas
Bishop f3 and trying to get rid of this
Bishop and some back rank back rank
stuff but honestly been that this one
looks looks extremely even and what I
can see is a very likely continuation is
is something like you know the Queen
moving both of these pawns falling maybe
the bishops being exchanged on this
square and I can see a lot of
liquidation happening in this game I
think this one's is quite even actually
alright very well and moving on Gregory
katana versus Denis cut reach of Bosnia
USA and Bosnia right
now the ketteridge if you aren't
familiar he is a former Bosnian national
champion against a US Championship
better in here so this game we have
White has a bishop pair yeah what do we
have here quite low on time is CAD rich
I'm just gonna sneak in a cheat if he
moves back because I see that I just
wanted to show this because it's an
intentional sacrifice so it wasn't like
you know we won material or something as
casualty was Kodama of who intentionally
sacrificed here Bishop takes d6 and the
whole idea is whether he takes this or
lets him his [ __ ] punch III be taken he
wants to take this pawn on b7 and say
that this a pond is just marching home
and you got that Bishop on f3
controlling the aid squares is kind of
like a perfect bodyguard just assuring
it right down the a file and with a
minute less than a minute and a half on
the clock for for CAD rich here you've
got to be sweating a little bit as Kai
demouth has to sort of decide does he
take with the rope or the bishop for
example rook takes b7 here let's say if
rope takes takes takes takes we would
have rook e1 check rook a one I suppose
in fairness I should probably put the
King on f2 or k1 a six so this something
like this wouldn't be quite enough
because the black rook would now stop
this pawn and then now the King can just
walk in but I think the more dangerous
of the two is the idea of maybe taking
with the with the bishop but I think in
any case what black is trying to do is
give a check and get that rook to a one
ASAP because I think you have to stop
this pawn from behind since getting over
to a a just doesn't look possible with
the bishop there I'm not sure if this is
enough to to win we have a move he
played Bishop takes d6 so let's say rook
takes d6
and pawn can be taken in a number of
ways here Bishop takes p7 we have maybe
rook check something like rook rook a1
and I mean if I take this pawn we can
see that that white is playing for the
win right if I've got these two pawns
here the bishop on b7 I always have a
six you have to leave a rook on the a
file so I should be playing for the win
here as as kadanoff so probably a
probably a good sacrifice by him and we
see some moves these moves are really
gonna come quickly because I think I
Donovan knows exactly the the
calculation he's on and and kadra just
got a minute and a half basically check
King h2r up tasty six right and I think
I don't know this is probably going to
be able to take both of these pawns here
I'm not sure and but whether or not that
final position is winning remains to be
seen because even a position where let's
say you know you get the rope for the
bishop but a lot of these pawns
disappear something like that may also
just be a draw as a Brooke hand game so
it's not it's not clear yet but I think
I dunno is is definitely happening here
he's got the people on the tail use of
the C pawn to take something like Bishop
takes b7 looks looks like the move here
if you play rook takes e5 I mean you
could also do this but I think the
b-pawn is is much more important to take
facilitates the a pawn running down the
board so I have a feeling he's probably
about to play Bishop takes Bishop takes
b7 here
well while he's on that thing let's go
back to group a vasily Ivanka curses
vara Cobian and you know what Cobian was
really really excited about this game
today
oh yes excited to play Chucky he said
when he comes in take a picture of us at
the board I was like absolutely yes sir
yeah no that's that's great no but
vasily von Schuch is it's definitely a
legend and looks like this is a bar he's
got him right down to the ropes here
right is that that's less than he's got
less than a minute there right and eight
moves left to go until time control yeah
I tell you if if Yvonne check could
possibly have a weakness it's got to be
how scramble e he can get how jittery he
can get in a time scramble he he's very
capable of finding the good moves but
somehow even when he makes a good move
he looks like he's blundering just
doesn't have that that confidence of a
blitz player playing under under time
pressure but you can't underestimate him
that's the thing he will find the good
moves in time pressure but we have far
it looks like they started from a French
and now now we're here we've got that
nice blockade on d4 for Yvonne shook and
what move has var just played I'm
getting nervous for Yvonne trick here
Queen a8 was just played and what will
happen here f5 there's always night h4
as an idea just to corral that pawn the
Queen maybe wants to sneak into a seven
the reason I think black is doing so
well here is you've always got King h7
just as like a fail-safe nice spot for
your King not gonna be in any trouble g3
was just played by Yvonne shook with not
a lot of time on the clock but he's
dealing with the move Knight h4 there if
I'm if I'm barred here I'm really
thinking about a move like King h7 just
prophylactic getting off the last rank
you don't want to deal with Jack and
Queen d8 coming really quickly so if I
played it for example Queen less a queen
a7 I just wouldn't want to have to
calculate something like this
maybe this is playable ah who knows in
fact it probably is with like Knight h4
and take here and you know let's say
we're not getting mated but all this all
this stuff is very very very scary to
calculate so I feel like my instinct
would be to play king h7 and he has he's
played King h7 here I think that's a
great move just sort of passed the ball
back to you von Schuch and say okay you
movement yeah yeah you go ahead because
King h7 is gonna be well placed and Evon
shook time is ticking down he has to
move he simply has the moving he's
played King g2 I mean this is just I
think var is sort of like bobbing for
apples here
it's like whether or not he can get one
being being the only question will he
get a blender out of Eve on trick he's
got 6 more moves to make he's got a find
position I should say that is there's
nothing wrong with Eve on chicks
position I just think if he survives
these these next six moves then you can
sort of recalibrate and sort of relax
but surviving against tricky tricky var
for the next six moves that's going to
be the real test for von Schuch here
well you've got to think that as a
player gets older they're quick chess
skills might diminish seemingly at first
at right at least
so yeah that's being put to the test
right now we do have another result in
Group A News Nick and Jeffrey Zhang have
drawn their game they've drawn they've
drawn it looks puzzling to me honestly
because it looked like Nick proposed a
Queen trade and then the notation ends
and it's draw III honestly find that
very surprising I might might have to go
inquire mr. Nisshin excuse me sir going
on I thought he had a better chances
based on the position as we looked at it
so in any case perhaps my evaluation was
just off in any case it seemed like he
was on the safer side of that draw so he
was sort of dictating things maybe he
had a little bit to play for but he
decided you know day one let me just get
some points on the board jump off to
that early tournament Lee
then my early turn the lead but okay
safe safe result for fern is Macbeth I'm
Geoffrey Jonah I'm feeling pretty good
about that off the hook a little bit I
think we've almost hit all of our games
except in Group B well we have Nicholas
Theodore o versus Alexia Sorokin let's
take a look at that Greece vs. Russia
and this was Sorokin this was the
feeding master who were talking about
who's got a higher fee rating than me
been good he's skipping the eim title
he's trying my third GM norm this time
and I'm gonna skip it yeah that looks
like the plan this position though I
think he's got his work cut out for him
as you know quick pawn count reveals
that that white is actually two
connected pawns up here two connected
pawns up
we definitely have a pair of hanging
pawns but let's not forget it's white to
move here these guys are very close to
time control so I don't think that that
that's gonna be a real issue then like
you know players blundering or something
only a couple more moves to make for
Sorokin here but I'm a little a little
worried a little concerned if I'm black
because White's got these pawns under
control only the D pawn is dangerous
that the e pawn is stopped by this poem
f2 and whites King is it's totally safe
here on g2 and I think that's really
important in end games
that's why I was mentioning in the
endgame that nation X was just and even
the then game that var just had was king
safety as soon as there's no checks for
that king you sort of rely on that and
time scrambles and stuff they just don't
have to worry about your king I think
that's a very really big deal so you got
this King on f6 which is always going to
be vulnerable to some checks discover
checks pieces arriving close to the king
whereas this King on g2 is is completely
safe so I think Sorokin here is
definitely worse for wear but if he can
connect his pawns here and try to say
that this D pawn is worth you know at
least a pawn in compensation that's
gonna be how he tries to justify his
position here but but white is I think
white is playing for the win here Ben
yeah those two pawns that tell the story
for me okay we're gonna have some
interviews here first there
coming in soon because let's go to our
game of the day in Group A Bach and Liam
Lee right and it looks like the
Vietnamese player is coming out in the
better better end I think sir well okay
somehow you got a this is like the guys
snuck behind the defense because where
did this pawn start I think that I think
it was actually an F pawn so went at
five and then it looks like he captured
on on e4 and snot get ahead to e3 so
that this is a that's like a that's like
a football rep right there if Bach has
some some unwelcome visitors in his home
right and yeah this is this is not
looking good for Benjamin who's also on
seconds I should say he's out he's
playing on the increment it looks like
34 seconds on the clock tells me he made
it move the four seconds right so he is
he's not comfortable here this Bishop on
c8 we should also mention is it's got a
look at that I mean it's just
restricting every single pawn that white
could think about moving forward this
Bishop on a1 just completely blunted by
that Bishop on c5 if that bishop arrives
there I am so scared for for Benjamin in
this position it looks like it's going
south very quickly putting that bishop
against the King and just getting ready
for d3 and e2 know the disposition is
probably probably the one that that's
the easiest to evaluate that we've
looked at so far I think this is a very
serious just winning advantage for for
look along here and he's gonna spend
some time just double-check things but I
think he's he's very confident here do
you think this game would end soon do I
think it would end soon yes yes I do yes
I do that's my big prediction I'm sure
that's an impressive thing to say not
many people would do a yes or no answer
not many people would go out on a limb
you know risk their reputation like that
but but here on the show up and I put
myself out there a real word of Valor
here
Group B by G&G versus yet in Stein
Grimson the other top ranked player is
prevailing it looks like what's going on
here
hmm some tactics maybe some tactics well
so Brooke e6 is is essentially forced
okay he's already played rookie six yeah
that's a no-brainer
got to play rookie six to defend your
bishop here now he can play queen Shaq
King age seven and queen takes on a
seven and I'm sort of wondering what's I
think it's Bishop b5 that's probably the
issue so it's gonna be Queen check here
and then it's at Bishop b5 or maybe
Bishop a4 not sure he can throw in a
check here if he wants and for example
it wouldn't be in my interest to play
maybe this move because for example g4
looks quite strong here otherwise
Bishop d5 also looks looks good hit that
rook and maybe just take this pawn on a
7x so Bishop b5 defends this pawn
because in this position if I took the
pawn then maybe Bishop takes on Bishop
takes on c4 and maybe he's still in it
but I think some combination of Bishop
to e4 and Bishop to d5 bye-bye that's a
good one by Jin sheet bye-bye Jin she
yeah so a combination of that bye-bye
Jin she will definitely be definitely be
enough here as both players under under
two minutes and we have another result
in Group B it's our third draw of the
day Ehrenburg and mr. I have battled
down to two kings on the board only
right so that one is a little more
expected at least right my eyes I think
that one was quite draws yeah looks like
we're gonna have some decisions though
here today oh yeah no well that's the
thing Ben you get those those squeaky
drawers out of the way and then you let
the I mean there's gonna be some some
bloodshed on I think on the first round
here that's the fun of these kinds of
tournaments you know so I think field
Cup 2018 right right right
you know it's more like 40 draws exactly
yeah
okay so what next
Stephen shirk Akopian whoa yeah Yvonne
Chaka Cobian let's go back to that game
Group A okay you find shook and Akopian
Cobian might be happy well I I mean the
the only question was whether or not
that time pressure was gonna play factor
and of course it always does as we can
see here on the board the the issue is
that the pieces are starting to really
invade the position you've got this
loose loose pawn here I cannot believe
that he played them of g4 because I mean
I thought that leaving the pawn on g3
just restricting that night everywhere
that it wants to go would be ideal but
he's played to move g4 and he's actually
rather rather manly decision Fannie's
but King g3 so he's replaced that pawn
with a king saying like king can do the
exact same thing and then maybe I want
to play h4 and h5 or something so the
only way that you can justify something
like this is if you're saying that your
opponent really has nothing to do like
if they if they don't have any moves
then you can get away with this stuff so
he's saying like the Queen you know
can't come into any of these squares
he's saying the rook can't go to b2 b3
b4 b5 right he's sort of saying that
I've got everything covered you can't
get in my position and if that's the
case hey you know h4 h5 suddenly I'm
pressing when I just like storm you with
these pawns but that's an impressive
that's a bold statement there's no way
in the position all right so you're
saying that's a mistake I think that
that's very cavalier I think that's very
cavalier with with less than two minutes
this is the type of expansion that could
get you in trouble for example so he's
he's played Queen d7 and in response to
this I believe now this could be
justified but you know Queen a6 and and
maybe threatening to get in with Queen
d3 looks looks quite looks quite serious
he's played the move Queen c5 will just
stick with the
the game moves here queen c5 so what's
he doing here he wants to play while
obviously Queen takes Knight but also
Queen c1 and I mean Benson as soon as
Queen g1 becomes a threat as soon as
Queen e1 becomes a threat Queen takes f4
queen c1 facilitates rook takes pawn I'm
hitting the knight and if you move your
knight all of a sudden rook III comes in
the position like this seems like just
completely unnecessary from from you von
Schuch I'm quite concerned it looks like
a cobia knows that he has him on shaky
ground look at the body language right
here I mean to be fair though a von
Schuch has looked like that from the
moment he walked in right probably
because he was a little bit late to the
round we get a little bit of a closer
shot of the board here it was pretty
interesting yeah he's just taking the
pawn on a for you von Schuch and that
was actually his 40th move so so that's
his time control move so that's what
he's looking at the score sheet there I
mean he's got a lot to think about here
but I think that's a big relief that he
doesn't have to make any more moves on
30 seconds that that is a big deal for
him so he'll be happy with that and at
the very least had there been let's say
two or three more moves that you would
have to play in time pressure here I
think is almost game over as the Queen
is invading but at least here bars are
gonna make a move and probably will
probably see von Schuch go in the think
tank and really try to deal with the
fact that I think a Cobian could
actually be crashing through here with
the Queen very well shall we dance
around to another game
absolutely yeah I know this looks like
it's about to hit time control things
are gonna slow down so how about some of
the other ones
tari Hanson piqued my interest let's see
here yeah that was one thing that I
basically knew was gonna get extremely
tactical and probably you know if tari
holds things steady it should be in his
favor but now both players down to a
minute minute and a half I'm just gonna
cheat and see where things went from
when we last looked white get that pawn
all the way to d7 and
now tari to move in a
I feel like you can you can take back
but tari has gone for the more
calculated approach and he's just play
tonight takes f6 so we're gonna see
Bishop takes f6 here and I guess that's
black you have to take on d7 I mean you
can throw in takes on h2 but in this
position after Bishop takes f6 which is
on the board you've got to play either
takes on h2 so that's a double check or
rook takes d7 so something like let's
say takes here takes rook takes d7 takes
takes and we got this position to
evaluate which honestly should be I want
to say that it's winning for white maybe
it requires a bit of a bit of a job with
technique but I have to say this this
this looks like it should be good enough
so there must be enhancing us to keep
relying on tactics here I've just looked
at this position and I see Hansen's come
up with this move so that tactics are
flying here Ben what's going on now
c4 right so I guess first of all if
Queen takes on c5 then this one is more
or less force after King takes is he
saying that I think he's saying that
there's a draw here you must be trying
to say that there's a draw here which is
which is believable which is believable
okay there's Bishop takes you four or
two to think about this Queen g4 at the
end of the days you can always grab that
Bishop later on but okay I could I could
believe there's a draw here again Bishop
d4 as you mentioned is the other very
serious consideration if Queen takes
bishop doesn't work but it's hard to
tell sometimes in these positions
whether it move is out of desperation or
whether it's it's actually a shot in the
dark that that's someone missed bishop
before is the other move and okay maybe
rook d7 or something with the idea that
if you take maybe I play rook takes and
all of a sudden all of a sudden I have
some tactics so he took he took yeah so
this was this was the thing he he took
here then and to me it's more or less
forced that you've just got to go for
for this line right were you just I
didn't see the D perpetual but he's
trying to go for something like this and
after king e - which is the only way to
make progress I believe maybe he's going
to play maybe he's gonna play King f1
and and try to bring the Queen back to
to cover the checks that way because if
Queen h3 came there and I you know at
this point you start to run away start
to run away
so we'll see this play out but you know
it would be a little surprising down a
full rope if if there was just a draw
here I have a feeling that the torii
might emerge victorious in these
complications yeah I'm not a believer
that there's just a perpetual check on
the board when the King seems to be able
to run to d2 and get to the Queen side
yeah so he has to decide where to put
the king but I think King g2 or King g1
is is either one should be fine here I
think that the Ataris gonna win this
game
yeah it looks like it right now let's
check in with Rey Robson in Rustom Cosmo
shadow in Group A this is another game
that has made time control but Ray
Robson is in the driver's seat
oh wait we have a result bhaijan she has
defeated Stein grin crimson in in their
first game of this tournament and ginchy
remember by is the top seat in Group B
right so let's see if anyone can stop
him this is the very first decisive game
at the event and we will see if we can
talk with bhaijan she in just a moment
right yeah I see the final position of
that game that's that's quite impressive
there yep so that game is has just
finished and more or less in the in the
fashion that we that we kind of expected
there the black king is just not gonna
survive on g5 very long that's for sure
I think there's a forcemeat or something
very close there at the end so yeah
that'll do it I know the game about to
end we got to go to bak and Liam Lee
yeah in Group A I see that is probably
there you go just finished alright and
that is that's an official result that
Benjamin Bach has has gone down here I
mean when it looks like when you don't
know like which side the pieces are on
that's probably bad news for for white
gray those could be pawns set up for the
next game those could be black pawns
that have gone all the way up the board
but that's very scary to face there
those pawns are one of them at least is
gonna become
cleaning and yet Benjamin just doesn't
doesn't stand a chance here with E one
Queen or eat XD one coming next
okay so no surprises yet we have our two
top seeds
I dried first blood right but I'm just I
don't want to miss any other results
that might be coming in pretty quickly
here right yeah the the two games in
group a it looks like so ray Robson
Andrew stem chasm jonov are still
playing that opposite Bishop and Queen
and gain which honestly just from
looking at the position black spawns
should be black spawn should be falling
here this King has a really really nice
place to hide on h3 this Bishop comes to
d5e six takes out five
I think this position is actually
totally lost for for chasm Janov whereas
blacks extra pawn it's over there in a
six imagine I could take that pond put
it over on g6 then I would have the same
position white has safe place for my
King on h6 but no the complete opposite
this King is just exposed I think that
if Ray Robson just gets a couple moves
in here Bishop e5 you can never force
the Queen exchange I'll never take it
and the Queen is actually tied down to
defending the pawn so it really can't
move too many different places so I
think that Ray Robson is actually
incredibly close to closing this off
even though it's even material opposite
bishops and they've made time control I
actually think this game could end very
quickly also Atari and Hansen is is
looking to be wrapping up very quickly
take a look at that one rights yeah no
so so taking that bishop on f6 is is
Hansen saying there's no perpetual right
and if there's no perpetual then it's
clear that white has moves like Queen d4
just that the very least that should be
enough apart from that there's a sea
pond hanging maybe you can even just
play for checkmate here but but yes this
looks like Orient are you should should
take care of business here and they've
made time control but you know when once
you make time control and you're staring
at a position like this as black it's
it's not that motivating to continue
white is clearly in the driver's seat
here up material and survived the attack
there well I am on a we do have by Jin
Chi outside getting ready to come in for
an interview
so while you take a look at what we have
left I will bid you farewell and go get
our guest awesome looking forward to
that yeah let's see who else we have
still playing here we have the we have
the game of Hanson that looks like it's
wrapping up in the a group we also have
this fairly interesting game between
Yvonne shook and Akopian
and this one is one that has hit time
control and very concerning for for
Yvonne shock just with the fact that all
these pieces are sort of gathering
around the white king but as I was
mentioning it's really fortunate for
Yvonne check that he hit time control
when he did because now his position he
can sort of collect himself in this
position and say that this knight on g6
is not not entering not entering the
position f4 is the only delicate square
if you play rook takes at b2 just to
show an example here white doesn't have
to be too concerned about something like
this after Queen before actually what we
see is the queen guards the F pawn the
only tender square in the position and
meanwhile I can actually sort of advance
this pawn off the board and look at this
hero Knight it stops all the checks on
the third
it stops a black queen from checking on
g1 and it stops it from checking with E
1 so this Knight just completely
protects the the white king here and
that actually means that Ivana
Exposition is looking fairly solid
I think he's recovered a lot there and
looks looks fairly strong so I think
Yvonne trick is gonna be gonna be happy
to to have survived that time scramble
and his positions looking a lot more
solid against against var compared to
when we looked at it before in that time
scramble so yeah things definitely
looking good therefore for Yvonne shook
and we see VARs going into the think
tank I don't think he has to be too
concerned about actually losing the
position but he's probably trying to see
if if you can still poke poke around
that King position there
this position is looking good
we also had I think this position was
the only other one still going in the in
the other game but we're getting getting
set up here for for a interview with
with by Jim she who is were getting set
up here hello hi nice to meet you nice
to meet you bye Jen she joining us he
just finished his his game just bring
that up on the screen but congrats for
the for the win obviously it's round
it's nice to start off that way yeah
yeah this that's a good start
yeah yeah so let's bring up the position
here and we'll just get you maybe I'll
play around with the mouse but just sort
of talk us through how the how the game
went for for you I guess in the in the
opening of the game oh yeah
so go ahead I I didn't before I have in
my death base I didn't see my opponent
played have play Bishop e7 before HBO
that is a surprise yeah that's that's a
surprise okay what were you expecting
then um be sure before Aldi take some c4
right okay so he played Bishop e7 which
was a surprise but I guess thankfully
it's not like a surprise move yeah yeah
it's still familiar to us right I have
three castle yeah so after here here I
choose Queen c2 I think it is also as a
surprise to him too heavy was your turn
for surprise yeah but I'm not sure DT
prepared is lying
I haven't played Queen c2 in in three
years
okay in these three years so so I think
you rather have a surprise okay yeah the
secret weapon from long ago that's it
okay c5 yeah
takes Queen a 593 yeah and I guess after
this you sometimes you sort of have the
opinion that things might just liquidate
a lot symmetrical position but yeah but
white is usually
pretty comfortable right with this
bishop on my g2 here so were you pretty
were you pretty satisfied with with how
you came out of the opening
yes I do so unto I might move Knight ft
6 9 ft 2 right that is all my
preparation right yeah ft 2 I had it
analyzed this before okay and I think I
can get a easier position to play easier
position yeah and that's that's
sometimes all you need just the easiest
issue yeah so c3 was something that you
yeah I don't know about c3 right I'm not
sure so so I I spend some time here
mm-hmm
yeah because this looks this looks very
very normal take the business and this
might I do my I'm not sure about after
c3 I can also take with my pawn right
with BC 3 and I thought he might play
Bishop e5 here mm-hm and 1994 you should
see seven and I think this is this might
be good for black right okay that's
where people write so yeah take that
while you still can
yeah where he gets to keep it cuz yeah
the at least you've compromised your
pawn structure so it's got to be
concrete otherwise maybe maybe blackness
is doing well yeah now the c3 palm block
is c5 wrestle but it also opened b5 so
I'm not sure double edged right yeah
right that's true so we had this this
was actually his move Queen Queen g6 I
didn't see this move right yeah I
thought he might play Queen d5 or creamy
7 but I think queen g6 is a good move
mm-hmm and so my original idea was Queen
sees right here right that's that the
normal nice action yes but then I saw
maybe he can play e5 and prepared to
play Bishop g4 or 94u creates something
like this I think right like has a full
composition full come yeah so actually
you're you remove pawn takes c3 pretty
much deals is a knight on d4 permanently
yeah
so yeah so did mm-hmm so yeah B takes c3
and rook b8
we need some work actually I think maybe
it's better to play e5 instant off
through p8 just start with you 5 yeah
and I will also play Queen Queen 84 here
because if I play rook at d1 or okb-1 he
has Bishop f5 right so it's not on
though I think maybe so let's say here
you v e5 I want to play Queen before
Queen 8 for yes yeah
just put the pressure I think this is
maybe also better for white mm-hmm what
has a slight slight advantage but I
guess this is better then she's better
than the game Yeah Yeah right
yeah because getting this Bishop out
seemed seem to be crucial in the game
well what actually happened was so now
he still have to play e5 then right have
to get the bishop out Bishop g4 and this
is back to when you chose to play B
takes c3 you're dealing with this yeah
pressure a lot a lot easier now just
rook to Queen age 5 and and now you
decided to go for this I kind of forcing
continuation I see a live and it seems
like things just work out for for you at
the end of yes calculations but how did
you feel about this position liquidating
um now what has a knowledge another
option is 97 right and but I think he
has bt8 and if I play Queen c2 here he
has rook FD 8 so it's right and it's a
little yeah little going there yes
it's not good boy that's a good point
okay
also just went for tonight b7 yeah I
think that's a right move and now he he
cannot play you should have three
because chief all right yeah that's very
nice
yeah it is very important that he cannot
exchange that be shot right no g4 is
pretty key actually to the hole you're
lying here yeah yep so I think he has to
take on b7 and then after Queen c6 he he
didn't laugh too much time so I think he
he also have has to face the time
pressure yeah he has to face the time
pressure because it's probably not that
bad but but when you combine it with the
time pressure it seemed like yeah end up
making some mistakes that's also that's
very hard for black to play yeah I think
yeah that's what it seemed like here
because it really realistically position
is not not that bad probably yeah this
was a nice move yeah this is a nice move
yeah no this is especially when you're
under the time pressure is seems like oh
I was so lucky to find this move this
one this one's really good because yeah
I think when he played Luke fz8 I
thought I thought this move looks a
little bit weird for where to me right
and I'm trying there should be something
yeah yeah right yeah so route B to I
think honestly after that move that kind
of give you and also h3 is that also a
good move right so you got this
obviously g4 but you also prevent the
bishop from coming back at this way yeah
yeah it's really annoying for him so he
cannot play Bishop d3 here because I
have 26 right Andrew P 128 that's funny
yeah there you go very nice take 63
everything falls with check yeah right
so so actually he had to bring the
bishop back this way head play then
everything actually just comes with
tempo at the yeah at the end I think I
think here is when you polite
right yeah here with the epon hanging
with a seven hanging especially as
everything has a tempo c4 yeah yeah this
is leeks and then after rookie six I
think we joined as well at this position
near the end and I'm not sure about
Queen they static here right is there
maybe some fish before that smell
original idea right it should be for a
five it should be five and you're
probably probably he would play route
kept six
well yeah but anyways Whitney yeah it
should be winning for sure I mean
there's no no big threats and got a
couple pawns hanging as well yeah that's
right maybe this is easier full full I
to week right yeah
because even stuff like this and yeah he
has to go okay like h4 yeah yeah but
it's a winning no question yeah no
question so yep then then just the
finish was was like this and Queen takes
e5 and very similar position the last
line before and and did he actually
played h4 and resigned
no he's time ran down time right now
okay well it wasn't sure if it looked
like that was the case yeah I thought I
would play
Queenie she Queen aged eight here right
already salad I think anyways yeah boy
and at this point you're just did you're
finishing the job
yeah no so so I mean pretty uh it looked
like you had some nice moves in that
game Brooke d2 was a nice wonder there's
some especially G for making sure that
worked in the calculations so yeah seems
like a good game for for you you from
China so is this your first time in st.
Louis or you played these terms before I
haven't this is the first time first
time but I have been doing in this
January okay okay so used to st. Louis
but first the first tournament so
there's obviously that's a good start
yeah thank you
good so you're looking forward to the
next rounds and obviously if you keep
keep winning we might see more of you
all right well thanks very much and
thanks for going over the game
thank you bhaijan she coming off win in
the first round is always a good feeling
always a good feeling and nice of him to
take us through nice of him to take us
through his game there so what do we
have still going on here there we go
I think this was exactly how I thought
this one was was going to turn out Queen
before and question for me is really
does this does this pawn really get past
a five if black just sort of shuffles
Queen e2 and Queen a two so far vara
went into this endgame yvonne Shooks
comfortable here and I think we have
this game as well between tari and
Hansen looks like it's it's pretty much
concluding right here as as Eric was
going for maybe a perpetual check but
that didn't pan out before the time
control and now with that pawn on d7 we
see Hansen has officially resigned and
yeah there's just no no stopping that
pawn kit end game is completely winning
Ataris up material is up a lot of time
and of course things things are not
working out here once the Queens are
traded off and there's no more perpetual
check threats for for Eric so a win for
Aria and Terry as well as we see the
score sheets being signed there and
that's another decisive results does
that affect you personally
does it affect me like does it feel like
I lost half of that yes or it doesn't
hurt you right here where it counts it
does it does maybe not 5050 I think that
would be disingenuous but but you know I
feel the sting a little bit you know one
Chesbrough goes down y'all I'll feel
that that sting just a little bit and so
absolutes gonna know it's connection
yeah how many chess bras are there today
anyway
well benders is an application procedure
there's a
hazing process you know I mean anyone
can be a chess probably in the tens the
hundreds I mean probably in the maybe
the ten ten something tens and tens the
tens of tens and just exactly exactly I
might be too many okay so we have one
game left in Group B radar overseas
Sorokin right and two games left in a
and you just glanced at Yvonne trucks
game is that right yeah I was just
looking at Yvonne check-in far Yvonne
chick seems to have survived sort of the
the worst of it but I'm not sure if I
could say there's more than a and I draw
on hand but I think you've on trick is
the one pushing if anyone and I guess
our other game is is that one that I was
pretty sure was going to be a win for
Ray Robson now I don't know how winning
it still is but but to me white skiing
is so safe here and there are pawns
falling all over the place so I think
Ray Robson is a clear favorite in this
game so I'm I'm expecting Robson to win
and I'm probably expecting a draw
between var and Yvonne shook and then in
Group B I'm just currently predicting
that that that rook end game between the
Sorokin and Nicholas theodoro would
would also be also be a draw based on
how it looks but some decent winning
chances for Nicholas so that's what it
looks like so far we got the three three
remaining games and we've already had
quitted quite a few results right well
it's been a fun day and I know we're
coming unfortunately to the end of our
time together here at u.s. chess champs
calm the games continue but we we have
results first of all to show you let me
show you the results in group 8 thus far
we still have two games pending as we
said but the big winners today so far
are en tari and seed number one liam lee
and let's take a look at our B group
standings our results rather only one
game left there you think it's a draw
yeah it looks like it's its draw so that
actually means that you know first seed
by ginchy you just joined us on the
broadcast is actually really leading
after day one potentially if that if
that result comes in as a draw
well we've had a good time so far as
today we hope that you join us tomorrow
remember the games begin two and a half
hours before we are on the air 1:00 p.m.
Central time right so you can go to us
chess champs dot-com and check out the
games and see the moves on the chest 24
board it's a lot of fun and then we'll
be on at 3:30 p.m. we want to announce
that today we had our highest viewership
for any seasonal classic any single day
of any seasonal classic in the history
of this youtube channel so thank you
very much for that let's even your tie
there Ben that it's not a bad tied all
wait maybe it was the hair must be a
combo second best purple hair I've ever
seen it Oh
second best well then I know who number
one and I think we a certain a certain
penguin exact st. Louis is her second
home tomorrow we'll be right back here
at the same time 3:30 p.m. Central Time
and remember hash tags bringing chess
classic US chess champ calm he's
Grandmaster I'm on Hamilton my name is
Ben Simon for the world's greatest
production B team Danny Machuca
Isaac Franz Tammy Hyde we say until
tomorrow so long from the Show Me State
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you